[Música]
tras calificarse como queridos amigos
este lunes el presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin y el presidente chino Pink
continúan su agenda en Moscú la visita
de chía Rusia marca una muestra de apoyo
al país el que invadió Ucrania Mientras
que el Primer Ministro japonés
visita sorpresivamente kiev vamos al
análisis de estas visitas con Eduardo
sili quien es el profesor investigador
en el departamento de política y cultura
de la Universidad Autónoma metropolitana
unidad de Xochimilco e integrante del
grupo de estudios sobre eurasia un
placer gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros y comenzamos si le parece
qué tal Muy buenos días Muchas gracias
por la invitación profesor sí es el
primer líder mundial que se reúne con
Putin Desde que la Corte Penal
Internacional emitió el viernes una
orden de arresto contra este líder ruso
por la deportación de niños ucranianos a
Rusia es entonces una visita que muestra
un descrédito al concepto de la cpi
si algunos lo considerarían Me parece
que así ya que pues la visita se da Pues
es de alto nivel se da Precisamente en
este contexto aunque también habría que
recordar que países como Estados Unidos
por ejemplo todavía no Son miembros
plenos de la de la Corte Penal
Internacional de manera que las críticas
habría que revalorizarlas a partir de
este tipo de detalles
Bueno uno de los temas que están girando
alrededor de la agenda de chillín
en Rusia es el interrogante de si podría
visitar Ucrania no se habla de Esto hace
varias semanas sin embargo lo único que
se ha decantado hasta el momento es que
podría darse una videollamada entre
selensky y xijin Pink el Premier
ministro el Primer Ministro japonés por
su parte hace hoy una visita inesperada
a kiev hablemos de estos dos encuentros
que muestran posturas completamente
diferentes
Sí de hecho la visita del Primer
Ministro japonés ha sido muy interesante
porque me parece que se da también en el
marco de una proyección internacional o
más global que quiere tener Japón sobre
todo para contrapesar un poco la pesada
influencia que está resultando tener
china en el este de asia en particular y
en el mundo en general no se ha
descartado me parece la videollamada
entre sillín Pin y el presidente de
Ucrania zelenski lo cual pues al final
hablaré un poco de los avances que puede
tener china
diplomáticos en este sentido quién sabe
la verdad yo dudo que que visite Ucrania
Es sobre todo por esta reciente visita a
Rusia pero me parece que tienen un poco
esa intención es decir ambas visitas de
contrapesar las proyecciones
internacionales de estos dos países
China y Japón que al final resultan
tener pues ciertas
ciertos encuentros ciertos choques en el
este asiático económicos históricos
etcétera y que son potencias no no
olvidemos esto ahora Putin le dijo a
xijin Pink que veía con respeto las
propuestas que hacía desde China para
resolver el conflicto de la guerra en
Ucrania quisiera preguntarle Cuáles son
esas propuestas Y qué opinión le merecen
Sí el plan de 12 puntos que ha
presentado
Pekín para resolver la crisis en Ucrania
Me parece que tiene que ver con una
intención que busca China de difundir en
el mundo una intención de fomentar otras
ideas alternativas a las tradicionales y
yo quiero enfatizar la idea sobre
seguridad
parte del plan de 12 puntos que china
propone es
considerar la seguridad de todos los
países incluida la de Rusia es decir
trata de resolver lo que se conoce como
El dilema de seguridad
Y eso implica pues tener que a fuerza
sentarse a dialogar no con con Rusia a
pesar de que Rusia ha sido considerado
como el agresor en la guerra en Ucrania
de manera que me parece que ese es uno
de los puntos nodales del de la solución
política que le denomina Pekín
el lo que le llama la seguridad integral
no para todas y todos Ya que eso también
incluso puede ser del interés de china
en sus propios problemas geopolíticos
como puede ser el asunto en el estrecho
de Taiwán o en el mar del sur de China
bien china podría ser un actor clave en
la Guerra de Ucrania Porque además antes
de la guerra tenía amplias relaciones
con Ucrania en Estados Unidos y
occidente en general lo que piden es que
utilice su influencia para promover el
retiro de las tropas rusas eso no está
sucediendo a todas luces pero una
alianza entre Beijing y Moscú por el
contrario si se fortalece podría china
ejercer un cambio en la balanza de la
guerra
pues me parece que ya lo está ejerciendo
desde el momento en que
declararon su asociación sin límites
hace ya un año y en el momento en que
china ha mantenido a Rusia un poco en el
radar internacional porque los esfuerzos
de países como Europa Bueno pues
europeos de países como Estados Unidos
pues han sido o se han enfocado en
excluir a Rusia del sistema
internacional y la presencia de China Ha
logrado mantener Hasta cierto punto a
Rusia precisamente porque China o desde
china se piensa que es necesario
mantener la comunicación el diálogo la
interacción con Rusia no excluirlo por
completo porque eso a lo mejor de
acuerdo con los líderes chinos podría
llevar a un a un conflicto mucho mayor
entonces de alguna manera ya está
ejerciendo y también el hecho de que
selensky en un primer momento
haya dicho que el plan de solución de
este política de la crisis de Ucrania de
China puede ser algo de lo que habría
que hablar discutir no O sea lo está
considerando ahí vemos Ya la influencia
de china me parece como supuesto
mediador Aunque pues como también los
mismos chinos han dicho no hay
soluciones simples para problemas
complejos como puede ser el conflicto en
Ucrania pero ciertamente sí es un gran
mensaje a viva voz la visita de
Moscú por estos dos días Muchísimas
gracias es Eduardo sil y profesores del
departamento de política y cultura de la
Universidad Autónoma metropolitana
unidad de Xochimilco e integrante del
grupo de estudios sobre eurasia gracias
a usted Muchísimas gracias a nuestros
televidentes sigan con nosotros ya
regresamos con más de directo a América
[Música]